- We've got this 84-inch roller
and 100 two-liter bottles of soda.
Let's see what happens.
So we went to Costco to get all these.
We pretty much emptied out
their entire Coke collection,
just for you guys.
Don't feel bad for the wasted soda.
You shouldn't be drinking
that stuff anyway, kids, okay?
This is awesome.
What I want to see is
just pure explosions.
We've got Jarrod here shaking up bottles.
That's the next move.
We've got 'em all laid out.
We're gonna start shaking
'em and get crazy.
- [Both] Ehhh!
(all shout and laugh)
- Let's do this.
(explosions)
(laughs)
Yeah!
(bottles pop)
(electro music and bottles
fizzing loudly as they explode)
Oh man!
This is awesome! (laughs)
Oh oh oh oh oh oh!
(loud music as bottles pop)
Ooh. Ooh. Ooh, that is awesome.
Look at the chaos!
That's beautiful.
(pounding music)
Look at the carnage, we've got bottles
all the way over there in the corner.
Bottle caps were flying off.
It sounded like fireworks
for a second, it was awesome.
That was so much fun.
Why is exploding things so much fun?
I don't know, I'm not
searching for a deeper answer,
I just want to see more.
We should explode some more stuff, right?
(pounding music)